AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY. THIS IS THE COMMITTEE
EMERGING MANAGEMENT WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT EIGHT AM
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT GOV.
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS CONSIDER PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAY BE READ INTO
THE RECORD OR REPRINTED. ALL
ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON
THE SOMEBODY'S WEBSITE AT. W.
W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENTS.
THE COPPER WILL BE OPEN FOR
TENNIS OF THIS HEARING. THE
PUBLIC IS STRONGLY ENCOURAGED
TO PARTICIPATE VIA THE WEB
PORTAL REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
OR ON THE PHONE. ANY EMBER OF
THE PUBLIC. ATTENDING A HEARING
IN THE CAPITOL WOULD NEED TO
WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE
IN THE BUILDING. WE ENCORAGE
THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE TODAY SHERRIN BY
CALLING. 977-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
HOUSE RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN IN THE
FISSION HEARING. WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE AN EFFECT OF
DELIBERATION AND DISCUSSIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER FOR
FACILITATE THESE GOALS WE WILL
NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE.
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. SO
WITHOUT. SMITH QUITE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM OUR COMMITTEE
SECRETARY CAN IN TECH WORLD.
HERE YEAH HERE HERE. YEAH HOLD
ON. CALAVERAS HERE GALLAGHER
HERE RIGHT GREAT ABSENT MORE.
LORD. AND NOW THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED IN A QUORUM THIS
ORDER FIRST BUSINESS OF THIS-
HEARING DISAPPROVE OF THE BILLS
ON CONSENT THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ON CONSENT S. B. FIFTY TWO
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
REGARDING LOCAL EMERGENCIES
UNPLANNED POWER OUTAGES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A MOTION OF
SECOND. REGULAR THE MOTION
SECOND BY VICE CHAIR SUCH
COMBINES GALLAGHER. SECRETARY
CALDERON. I YES. RIGHT HI I
GRADUATED COLLEGE THREE FIVE
WALDRON CALDERON I WAS VERY
GALLAGHER RIGHT. FOR AND- THE
MOTION PASSED SO WE'RE JUST
WAITING ON SENATOR DODD OR
MCGUIRE. THE OTHER WAY. THAT
WAS REALLY COOL. THAT I WOULD
HAVE NEVER EVER HAD A HEARING
PROBLEM. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN AFFORD ME RUNNING OVER
THERE. YEAH. UP ON. TOP OF HI
GOOD AFTERNOON. YEAH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE YEAH IN ORDER
TO- OKAY. ALL OKAY. WHAT WILL
HAPPEN BURKE. THE NEW YORK I
LOVE MY FROM OFFICE FOR. TOPICS
BUT I IN ORDER KNOW WHAT IT
SAYS IN THE DENVER. NO GOING
DOWN IN FLAMES. WHAT. RIGHT.
YEAH REPUBLICAN. FOR THAT COULD.
SAN JOSE FOR THIS GROUP ON THE
BALLOT THE BARBECUE. RIGHT AT
THE BACK OF YEAH- SO MMHM HELLO
EVERYBODY. OKAY WHAT ABOUT
THEIR OKAY SURE. WE HAVE LIKE
AFTER EIGHTEEN YEAH HOPING TO
GET MORE PEOPLE LOCAL. THOSE
ARE. REALLY GOING TO CHANGE. MY
LIFE AND I. BECAUSE THE BUT
YEAH GOOD BUT WHAT COLOR ONE
FAMILIES IN NEED OF YEAH ONE
FIVE YEAH ALWAYS IN HERE
SOMETHING. WILL NOT BE HANDED
BECAUSE I. WORKING WITH. ABOUT
FOR SOMETIME AT THE END OF.
THERE OKAY YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH
I DO. YEAH WELCOME TO GO WITH
THE LADY WE HAD A VOTE OF OUR
GARBAGE ON SATURDAY. WHY
PROGRAM GLASSES THAT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T KEEP IT LIKE THAT
IT'S LIKE SUPER CLEAN RIGHT NOW
YEAH SUPER LOOK RIGHT. THE A.
RIVER LIKE THAT- YOU SHOULD. I
REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME IN THE
BUILDING THANK YOU SAID FOR
JOINING US TODAY. SLOWER THAT
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND START. SURE FIFTY
FOUR MISTER CHAIR IN MEMBER- I
WOULD LIKE BEGIN BY THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINE IN THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE FIVE I THANK
THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL. S.
B. ONE OH NINE ESTABLISHES THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY TECHNOLOGY
AND RESEARCH. AND DEVELOPMENT
WITH CAL- WITHIN CALLIE- WE US
ESTABLISHES AN ADVISORY BOARD
TO ENSURE THAT THE NEW OFFICES
ACTING EFFICIENTLY. AND
RESPONDING. TO THE NEEDS OF ALL
OUR CONSTITUENTS AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIANS FACE AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
EMERGENCIES IN RECENT YEARS.
AND THERE'S NO REASON TO EXPECT
THE NEW NORMAL TO GET BETTER.
ANYTIME SOON. FROM THE
WILDFIRES DROUGHTS FLOODS
EARTHQUAKES AND OIL SPILLS THE
STATE'S FACED WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREPARE
FOR AND BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
NATURAL AND MAN MADE. DISASTERS
THAT IS WHY THIS BILL IS BEING
CRAFTED TO TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO PROTECT AGAINST ALL
FORMS OF DISASTER. CALIFORNIA
IS A WORLD LEADER IN TECHNOLOGY
WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO LEVERAGE THIS ADVANTAGE. TO
ENSURE THAT WERE IN THE BEST
POSITION TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND WELFARE OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SB ONE ON I WAS
AMENDED LAST WEEK TO REMOVE
CERTAIN FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS. IN THE AD TO
MEMBERS TO THE ADVISORY BOARD.
ONE APPOINTEE BY THE ASSEMBLY
INVOLVED IN THE- PROTECTION OF
PRIVACY AND CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
ONE APPOINTEE. BY THE SENATE
INVOLVED IN VICTIM SERVICES.
THESE WERE TAKEN AS AN ATTEMPT
TO BEGIN ADDRESSING RECENT
CONCERNS RAISED BY PRIVACY AND
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS. FURTHER
THE MEMBERS TAKEN TODAY WILL
SPECIFIED THAT THE NEW OFFICE
WILL BE REQUIRED TO WORK WITH
CAL FIRE. REGARDING FIRE
PROTECTION TECHNOLOGIES. I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CONCERNED PARTIES AS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. ON THE LINE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL'S CHIEF
DANIEL STEFANO PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU CENTER
AND THANKS AGAIN FOR ACCEPTING
THE MAMMOTHS. SO WITHOUT
OPERATED WE HAVE- DANIEL FROM
THE FIRE CHIEF OF COSTA MESA
FIRE ON THE LINE. YES SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON IT
CHAIR ROAD REPAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
DAN STEFANO FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY OF COSTA MESA AND HAS
STATED PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF S. B. ONE OH NINE.
DURING THE LAST FEW YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED THE
WORST FIRES IN MODERN HISTORY
ID TWENTY TWENTY ALONE OVER TEN
THOUSAND WILDFIRES BURNED OVER
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION ACRES OF
LAND. AND TRAGICALLY THIRTY
THREE PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES
IN THE STATE OF DEVASTATING
EVENTS INCLUDING FIREFIGHTERS.
EXHILARATING FREQUENCY AND
SEVERITY OF THESE WILDFIRES
REQUIRES ALL CONNECTED WITH THE
FIRE SERVICE AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO RESEARCH AND
DEVELOP STATE OF THE ART
FIREBASE TECHNOLOGY. TO BETTER
FORECAST AND MONITOR MERGING
EVENTS INCLUDING PRE
POSITIONING OF RESOURCES. AND
PERSONNEL APPROPRIATELY TO
MINIMISE THE IMPACT OF SUCH
EVENTS. THE OFFICE OF PROPOSED
IN SB ONE OH NINE WILL
ESTABLISH AN ESSENTIAL FOCUSED
ON EMERGENCY. EMERGING NEW
DEVELOPMENTS AND WILL ASSIST
LOCAL AGENCIES AND ANALYZING
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGIES
TO MEET THEIR NEEDS AT THE AT
THAT LOCAL AND DISTRICT LEVEL.
WE DON'T WORKS BECAUSE THE NEW
OFFICES MODELED DIRECTLY AFTER
THE FEDERAL SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY DIRECTORATE WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL ALSO BE REPRESENTED ON THE
ADVISORY BOARD WHICH WILL
ANNUALLY REVIEW AND REPORT ON
THE WORK OF THE OFFICE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR. WE
ARE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY ASKS
FOR YES VOTE ON SB ONE OH NINE.
THANK YOU. BUT THERE'S A MOTION
A SECOND MOTION BY CECILIA
CORINNE SECOND HOMES CALDERON-
THANK YOU CHIU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM ALSO FOR SUPPORT. YES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
REDWOOD COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR DODD'S MEASURE. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM FOR
SUPPORT. OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE LINE TO ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ONE OH NINE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND YOU THAT YOU DO
NEED TO PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE RECORD ONCE WE CALL
YOUR FLIGHT NUMBER. AND WILL
FIRST GO TO THE LIGHT NUMBER OF
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS DR
MOMMA CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF-
ON INTO FOR AND ON BEHALF OF
OUR DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND GENESIS
CORPORATION AS WELL THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWELVE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
MEXICO LIGHT NUMBER TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
DAMON CONKLIN ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL. ONE OH NINE. AND NEXT WE
GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CATHERINE AGREEMENT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE OF NINE THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER ALL YOUR ON BEHALF THE
NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO OTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT YOU MAKE PROCEED. THANK
YOU OPERATOR SO NOW MOVES TO
THE OPPOSITION OPERATE I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY ON
THE LINE FOR ON OPPOSITION-
JENNIFER JONES OF. ACLU
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS SHE ON
THE LINE. SHE IS ON THE LINE
MOST DON'T YOU ME ON MUTE YOUR
PHONE. YES THANK YOU I THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JENNIFER JOHN ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS THE BILL AS
AMENDED. AS AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO DEFENDING CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTIES IN
THE DIGITAL AGE INCLUDING
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS FROM
INVASIVE GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE. WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED WITH SENATE BILL ONE
ONLINE AND ITS UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTIONS THE THIRTY MINUTES
WILL KEEP BY STATE.
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE THREE THIRTY
ONE AERIAL CROP SURVEILLANCE
AND PREDICTIVE POLICING SYSTEMS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DEMONSTRATED
TO CAUSE HARM TO SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF SUCH
SYSTEMS THAT PROTECT AND
DEMONSTRATIONS WOULD ONLY
EXACERBATE THAT HARM. SB ONE
ONLINE AUTHORIZES THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT. TO FURTHER
DEVELOP SURVEILLANCE AND
POLICING TECHNOLOGIES THAT
COULD BE USED TO TARGET
COMMUNITIES AS THEY DEMAND A
MORE JACKSON. EQUITABLE FUTURE
FOR CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY. AND LYFT THE RAMP
TO BE ABLE APPROACH. THAT WE
WITNESSED NATIONWIDE LAST
SUMMER DURING ONE OF THE
LARGEST MOVEMENTS IN U. S.
HISTORY. INCLUDING DOCUMENTED
GOVERNMENT USES THAT AERIAL
SURVEILLANCE AND SOCIAL MEDIA
MONITORING. THIS MASSIVE EVENT
UNDERMINES PEOPLE'S FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT INSTILLING FEAR
RETRIBUTION FROM GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. WELL WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED LAST WEEK WE ASKED THAT
HE ACCEPTED ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO BE OFFERED TO THE
DRAFT I REMAIN CNCERNED BY
NARROWING THE DEFINITION OF
EMERGENCY THREAT. TO ONLY
NATURAL DISASTER AN
ENVIRONMENTAL EMERGENCY RELATED
EVENTS TO ENSURE THE SCOPE OF
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT IS LIMITED TO
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGIES ONLY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IMPROVING
WILDFIRE AND OUR NATURAL
DISASTER PREPARATION AND
RESPONSE. THIS WOMAN SURE THE
CALIFORNIANS ENGAGING IN
PROTESTS IN OTHER POLITICAL
SPEECH ARE NOT SUBJECTED TO
INCREASE SURVEILLANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION. SEE NON OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
REGARDING OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION.
OKAY WITH THAT THE RING BUT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FOR I THINK IT'S A- GREAT IDEA
AND CERTAINLY I THINK THAT
HAVING THIS- YOU KNOW THIS
AGENCY AND BEING ABLE TO REALLY
HONE IN N. NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CAN HELP US BE MORE
PREPAREDOBVIOUSLY SOMETHING IS
VERY COMMON TO BOTH OF US-
HAVING- DISTRICTS GONE THROUGH
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH- BUT-
I THINK. THERE'S SO MUCH THAT
CAN BE DONE- SO MANY
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE THAT CAN
HELP US BE USED SO MUCH MORE
RESPONSIVE SO I APPRECIATE THIS
AND WILL BE SUPPORTED TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- THE OTHER
QUESTION A QUESTION. NOT REALLY
QUESTION JUST A COMMENT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU HIS CENTER JOB
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- YOU
KNOW OF TO CURRENTLY A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES. ATTEMPT TO DO THIS
AND YOU SEE THE DISJOINTED
EFFORT OUT THERE. AS SOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY
AND SOME DON'T SOME DON'T EVEN
HAVE THE ABILITY TO. IT TO FIND
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT BEST SUITS
OUR AREA I THINK SOMETHING LIKE
THIS WILL HELP. AND ACCORDING
TO THAT EFFORT AND- YOU KNOW I
DON'T SEE IT AS MUCH OF A
SURVEILLANCE ISSUE IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT- BECAUSE WE CLEARLY
AREN'T REALLY GOOD AT IT YET-
HOW TO MANAGE AND- AND- MAKE
PLANS FOR. AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT- ISSUES- WE'VE BEEN
PLANNING THESE THINGS FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS AND YET WE
ARE STILL KIND OF BEHIND THE
CURVE EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
MAJOR INCIDENT. AND SO ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO USE CURRENT
TECHNOLOGY FOR THAT ADVANTAGE
AND BE ABLE. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT BY ALL OF OUR CAN- AND IN
A MORE. EFFORT SO THERE KIND
DOING THIS THING AND WHAT
BUYING ONE PROGRAM ONE V.
ANOTHER PROGRAM FROM ANOTHER
VENDOR AND GOING TO BE THEY
FINE OUT THAT IT WORK. FOR
THEIR CAN. AND IT'S A WASTE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT WAY I
THINK THIS AND THIS ACTUALLY
HELP SOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND IS
GONNA BE A GREAT RESOURCE FOR
COMMUNITIES OUT THERE AND- I AM
FULL SUPPORTER YOUR- BILL HERE
THANK YOU. THANK RUSHERN MORE
QUESTION COMPENSATE WITHOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR. THANK YOU US WITHOUT
WITHOUT THE MOTION SECOND THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY LIKE
CALDERON. YES HI RODRIGUEZ
PRIVATE SECTOR OKAY THERE ARE
STILL FIVE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
GREGORY AYE CALDERON. CALL JOHN
I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I AGREE.
WARD FOUR TO FIVE SIX EYES
THANK YOU THAT MEASURES UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH BRIDGET. ALL
THREE OF THE FOUR. REMIND THEM.
SOURCE TELLS PROVIDING
SECRETARY ONE OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR A CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS-
CONSECUTIVAS B. FIFTY TWO.
ABOARD FIVE OR FIVE SIX SIZE
NOW OKAY PERFECT PERFECT TIMING.
THANK YOU CENTER WHEN YOU HAVE
YOUR NEXT BILLS UP. SO NEXT
ITEMS ON THE JENNA'S SB THREE
FORTY ONE BY CENTER MCGUIRE-
WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
FIRST AND FOREMOST I JUST WANT
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR TIME
ANALYZING THE BILL. YOUR
SINCERE COMMUNICATION ALONG
WITH YOUR STATS AND JUST WANTED
TO HELP YOU SHOULD'VE I AM.
GOING TO BE ACCEPTING ACCEPTING
THE COMMITMENTS TODAY I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO SEND
THEM A GALLAGHER FOR. AGREEING
TO CO AUTHOR- IN FOR. HIS
TREMENDOUS PARTNERSHIP IF I
COULD JUST BE HONEST OVER THE
PAST. SEVERAL YEARS AND ALWAYS
USE THE FIRES. FOR A GREAT
PASSER ALONG WITH. CINNAMON
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR OUR PARTNERSHIP AND FIRES.
TO GET RIGHT INTO IT AND I'LL
KEEP IT SHORT MISTER CHAIR.
HERE'S WHAT THREE FORTY ONE
DIES NUMBER ONE IT PROVIDES THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
EXPLICIT AUTHORITY TO CREATE
BACKUP POWER RULES FOR CELL
TOWERS. LAND MINE OPERATIONS IN
CABLE PHONE SYSTEMS. NUMBER
TWO. IT DOES NOT TOUCH THE
CURRENT. PC PROCEEDINGS ON BACK
UP POWER. NOT ONE BIT. NUMBER
THREE IT MANDATES THE STATE
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO
SHARE INFORMATION THEY ALREADY
RECEIVE FROM TELECOM COMPANIES.
I NETWORK OUTAGES TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. I THE
REASON THIS IS SO CRITICAL IS
THAT THE C. P. C. AS YOU ALL
KNOW. IS CHARGED WITH KEEPING
THE NETWORKS UP AND RUNNING.
AND MAKING THEM MORE RESILIENT
BUT THEY CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE
THE STATUTORY. ABILITY TO SEE
THIS INFORMATION WHICH MEANS.
THAT THEY CAN'T INSURE THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE NETWORKS
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE. AND
WHY WE KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT
IS BECAUSE DURING TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS PLANNED PARENTHOOD
TO BUCKLE. AT ITS PEAK NEARLY
TWO MILLION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. HAVE THEIR LAND LINE
CELL PHONE AND CABLE SERVICE
INTERRUPTED. SB THREE FORTY ONE
IS A COMMON SENSE BILL TO MAKE
SURE THE TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
ARE DOING WHAT THEY NEED TO
IMPROVE THE STATE'S NINE ONE
NETWORKS. AND TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO CRUCIAL
INFORMATION. ABOUT OUTAGES
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE AND
IT'S ONE ALSO SAY THANK YOU. TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL
AS THE INDUSTRY FOR THEIR
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT. THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING HARD ON THIS BILL-
AND TRYING TO GET A STRIKE A
COMPROMISE ON ALL LEVELS. IN
YOU'VE BEEN A BIG PART OF IT
MISTER CHAIR JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU. TODAY WE HAVE TWO
INDIVIDUALS PREPARED FOR
TESTIMONY. RAY GUY HE IS THE
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF
ONTARIO. IN PRESENT ELECTED THE
CALIFORNIA. FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. WE ALSO. HAVE THE
ONE THE ONLY COREY CECIL ON THE
LINE REPRESENT THE STATE. SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR VOTES ARE.
ALL RIGHT THANK. THANKS AGAIN
SO FOR TAKE THE MAMMOTH. SO
OPERATOR DO WE DO HAVE A RAY.
OUR COREY ON THE LINE AND
WHOEVER LIKE TO GO FIRST.
THEY'RE BOTH ON. WHATEVER LIKE
A MEMBER. SURE AUGUST REGARD
I'M GONNA GO FIRST ABOUT OKAY
THAT'S FINE. OKAY A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GREG **** ALL PARTY FOR THE
CITY OF ONTARIO AND PRESIDENT
ELECT OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. THAT IS
AFTER AND POWER SHUT OFF THE
CLOCK THAT THEY HAVE SHOWN THAT
THE EMERGENCY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM NEEDS
TO BE IMPROVED. FOR OUR
RESIDENTS AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
WHAT DO WE LOOK AT THE CAMPFIRE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN UP IN
PARADISE. OR OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY
FIRESTORM. GETTING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE SAFELY EVACUATED IN THE
EARLY HOURS OF THE DISASTER IS
LIFE OR DEATH. AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND OUR RESIDENTS
NEED AND HAVE COME TO EXPECT
OUR PHONES TO WORK WHEN
DISASTER STRIKES. SB THREE
FORTY ONE WILL IMPROVE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS BY
CREATING STRONGER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. WHEN IT
COMES THE TELECOMMUNICATION
OUTAGES AND BACK UP POWER
SYSTEMS. DURING THE POWER
OUTAGES IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN NEARLY TWO MILLION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAVE THEIR LAND LINE CELL PHONE
AND CABLE SERVICE INTERRUPTED.
BUT SMALLER OUTAGES OCCUR AND
ARE REPORTED TO- YEAH.
DEMONSTRATING WEAKNESS AND ARE
MURKY COMMUNICATION SYSTEM. BUT
THE CPUC HAS NO IDEA WHEN
THEY'RE OCCURRING. SB THREE
FORTY ONE FOUR REQUIRE ONLY
HALF THE SHARE COMMUNITY
ISOLATION OUTAGE INFORMATION
WITH THE CPUC AND REQUIRES THE
CPUC TO RECORD THE LEGISLATURE
ON ACTION TAKEN USING COMMUNITY
ISOLATION OUTAGE INFORMATION.
THE CPUC REGULATES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WORKS FOR
CHOIR REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE
BACKUP POWER BUT TELCOS. REPORT
OUTAGES TO THEIR NETWORKS TO
THE- YEAH. FIFTY PSC IS NOT
ABLE TO FIND IF THAT OUTAGE
OCCURRED WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
CHIEF NEXT WONDER COREY COREY
ON THE LINE. YES SIR MR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THIS IS YOUR
MEMBERS COURSE ALTHOUGH ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
ON THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK
ON IT HAVING ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT NINE ONE ONE
OUTAGES VITAL NOT ONLY THE
PUBLIC BUT ALSO LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIRST RESPONDERS. FALTERING
OUTAGE MAP REQUIREMENTS WILL
MAKE THE SUPPORT INFORMATION
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND INTEREST THE
COMMITTEES TIME I'LL STOP THERE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND-
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU COR. OF WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND MOTION BY.
SICILIAN SECOND BY CHRIS. OF
WITH THAT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TESTIMONY AS OR ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
ANNOUNCING NONE. OPERATORS ARE
ANYONE ON THE LINE ON SUPPORT.
WE DO JUST AS A REMINDER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE RECORD ONCE YOUR
FLIGHT NUMBER IS CALLED UPON WE
GO TO LINE TWELVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE AND
MEMBERS DAMON CONKLIN ON BEHALF
OF. THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES ONE OF I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE SPACE THAT WE'RE IN SPROUT
SUPPORTED SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANKS WE
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBER
NOT YOUR NORMAL ON BEHALF OF
THE FIRE DISTRICT TO COMPLETION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WE GO TO LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTS THE OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. MEXICO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MIXTURE MEMBERS CALL YOU ORDER
SHALL BE AT THE NAPA COUNTY
BORDER TO BRIDGE THEY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AS WELL THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST OBSERVERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT. N. MEXICO TO LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. READ
MORE ON BEHALF OF THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK IF SUPPORT. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU OPERATOR. SO WITH THAT-
WILL MOVE ON TO FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR I BELIEVE
WE DO HAVE STEVE CARLSON FROM
C. T. I. C. T. I. A ON THE
LINE. IS A VITAL. OPERATOR CAN
YOU JUST CHECK ONE MORE TIME IF
WE HAVE STEVE CARLSON ON THE
LINE. MISTER CARLSON IF YOU ARE
ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO I DO NOT SEE YOUR NAME
LISTED. HE IS NOT RESPONDING
SIR OKAY THAT'S FINE THANK YOU
OPERATOR. I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE-
SOMEONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM I BELIEVE WE HAVE BERNIE
OROZCO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COME FORWARD AND ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE SIR. YES THANK YOU
HAVE A GERMAN RECENT MEMBERS
BERNIE OROZCO CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE FOR ONE. ARE YOU CLARIFY
THAT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF
BACKUP POWER AND FOR THE
MAPPING OF OUTAGE INFORMATION
TO CONSUMERS. THAT WAS ALREADY
ADOPTED IN FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS YEAR SO
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS BILL THAT IS HAPPENING-
NEXT MONTH WE WILL BE
SUBMITTING OUR- ACTION PLANS TO
THE P. YOU SEE ON HOW WE PLAN
ON DOING THAT. AND WE'RE WE
HAVE SOME CHALLENGES AND THEN
BY OCTOBER THIS YEAR WE WILL
DEPLOY THE VERY FIRST BACKUP
GENERATORS TO ALL CRITICAL
CUSTOMERS. IN HIGH FIRE THREAT
TO IN THREE AREAS AND SO TEN
MONTHS AFTER THAT ALL CUSTOMERS
IN HIGH FIRE THREAT TO IN THREE
AREAS WILL HAVE BACKUP
GENERATION. SO THIS IS
SOMETHING IS ALREADY IN PLACE
SO WHAT WE HAVE. BEFORE YOU TO
TODAY IS HOW BEST DO WE GO
ABOUT DOING THAT AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR WE
WANT TO THANK HIM. FOR
CONVENING THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES IN. TO KIND OF
HELP US GET THOSE PERMITS GOING
IN PLACE SO THAT'S FOR THAT
SENATOR WE ARE VERY THANKFUL-
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT. ON SOME OF THE OTER
PROVISIONS WRITTEN INTO THE-
THE DETAILS IS ALWAYS IN THE
LANGUAGE AND WE LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT PORTION THAT PORTION OF
IT. BUT AT THE MOMENT WE'RE
STILL. POSE BUT THANKFUL FOR
WORKING WITH THE CENTER. THANK
YOU IS OUR- ELSE IN THE ROOM NO
POSITION. SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE PHONES OPERATORS ARE
ANYONE ON THE LINE OPPOSITION.
YES WE DO HAVE BLANK TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS PAMELA SMITH ON BEHALF
OF CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS.
IN OPPOSITION. AND THERE'S NO
OTHER LINE IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU
SEEN THAT WILL BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. BY STERN QUESTION
YEAH GOING. SO ALL OF THIS HAS
A COST TO IT. YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT COST IS. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE PAST IS GONNA BE
DEPLOYING THE BACKUP ENERGY-
AND WE HAD A BILL LAST YEAR
THAT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED
SEVENTY TWO HOUR BACKUP POWER
FOR JUST SOME SPECIFIC CELL
SITES. THAT BILL DO NOT MAKE IT
OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY FIGHT TO BE
CANDID AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THEN TOOK
UP THE ISSUE THAT THEY DID TWO
DIFFERENT RULINGS THE FIRST
RULING WAS ON- MOBILE. TELECOM
WIRELESS IN THE SECOND WAS ON
LAND LINE THAT WAS EARLIER THIS
YEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE
THOSE COSTS IN IT IS GOING TO
BE A SIGNIFICANT COST FOR THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR. WHERE THEY
THE GUTS OF THIS BILL WILL DO
IS ALREADY REQUIRED. RIGHT NOW
THE STATE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ALREADY RECEIVES
INFORMATION ON WHY THE OUTAGE
HAPPENED. THAT'S WAS IN A
PREVIOUS BILL THAT WE BROUGHT
FORWARD THAT- THE ASSEMBLY ALSO
SUPPORTER AND I'M VERY GRATEFULFOR. THAT REALLY THE GOT TO
THIS BILL TAKES THE INFORMATION
THE STATE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ALREADY HAS. PROVIDED
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
RIGHT NOW THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION CANNOT GET ACCESS TO
THAT INFORMATION ABOUT WHY
THERE WAS- AN OUTAGE AND I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR WITH THIS BILL
ALSO DOES IS BROAD AND THEN
MAPPING AS WELL AS EXPANDS THE-
THAT THE INFORMATION COULD BE
CAPTURED. SO BERNIE WAS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR CABLE FOR
THROUGH SINCERE ENGAGEMENT- BUT
RIGHT NOW- WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THERE'S A DISASTER DECLARATION
AND MAPPING HAPPENS IF A TRUCK
HITS A TELL- A PIECE OF FIBER
AS IT DID TWO YEARS AGO GOING
UP THE HUMBLE. AND IT TOOK OUT
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS THERE IS NO MAPPY IT
TAKES IT IN FOR CONSISTENCY
CUSTOMERS DON'T LOOK IF THERE'S
A DISASTER OR FOR TRUNCATED
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHY THEIR
SERVICE ISN'T WORKING. AND SO
IT BRINGS CONSISTENCY BUT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE COST IS
BASED OFF OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES ACTION BECAUSE THE
BOOK OF THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
SHARING INFORMATION TO THE PC
WHO OVERSEES. TELECOM HERE IN
THE STATE AND ENSURE THAT THE
RESILIENCY IS GOING TO AFFECT
SO THE POLICY QUESTION THAT I
LOOK AT IS THERE IS A COST TO
IT HOUSE I CAST COST BORN IS
THAT COST BORNE BY RATEPAYERS.
WHO ARE SPECIFIC TO WHATEVER
COMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES THEY
ARE OR ARE IS AT A COST THAT
SHOULD BE BORNE BY FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. A SHARED COSTS.
BY AT LEAST A SHARED COST. BY
THE- WHO HAVE PAID. THIRTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF EXTRA
TAX MONEY THIS YEAR. IS THIS IS
I MEAN THIS IS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR OUR
PEOPLE'S SURVIVAL DURING
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE POWER
OUTAGES AND THINGS LKE THAT
AND- IF THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
COSTS TO IT IT WINDS UP BEING
BORN ON. IT TURNS IT TURNS UP
IN THE BILL'S ESPECIALLY IF THE
PC IS INVOLVED SO THEY'LL
APPROVE THOSE COST INCREASES
AND THAT MEANS LESS PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO AFFORD THOSE
SERVICES. SO YOU KNOW IT FOR ME
IT'S AND IT'S- YOU KNOW I'M-
I'M KIND OF CAUGHT HERE
BECAUSE- I ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
THE EFFORT. I JUST WISH WE
WOULD WORK ON THE POLICY OF
SHOULD THE STATE. SHOULD WE BE
USING AS THIS IS SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY- OF FUNDING THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY TO HELP OFFSET
THOSE COSTS SO MORE PEOPLE CAN
BE INVOLVED. IN IT SO THEY'RE
NOT PRICED OUT OF HAVING THE
SERVICES. BECAUSE THAT'S TO ME
THAT'S THE DANGER IS THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE THAT WILL BE PRICED
RIGHT OUT OF HAVING THESE
SERVICES. BECAUSE IF THIS IS A
HUGE COSTS BUT YOU SAY IT IS
AND IT'S ALL PASSED THROUGH ON
BILLS. YOU KNOW I I'VE WATCHED
MY BILL GO FROM 220-022-0050 IN
ABOUT ELEVEN MONTHS. AND
THERE'S JUST DIRECT I HAVEN'T
ADDED ANYTHING EFFECTIVE TAKEN
STEP AWAY FROM IT. EVENTUALLY
PEOPLE JUST CAN'T AFFORD IT I
THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACE HERE IN THE STATE. IS THAT
WE ARE- ONE LARGE FIRE AWAY.
ONE POWER SHUT OFF AWAY FROM
LOSING- TELECOM FOR TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THAT'S THE
COST BUT WHEN YOU CAN ACCESS AT
NINE ONE ONE. WHEN YOU DON'T
GET EMERGENCY ALERTS BUT WHEN
THAT TRUCK HIT THAT FIBER GOING
UP THE HUMBLE YOU COULDN'T
ACCESS ATM YOU COULD USE YOUR
CREDIT CARD AT LOCAL GROCERY
STORES THIS IS LITERALLY DAYS
ON END WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT THE COST TO THE ECONOMY
IS. WHEN THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
GOES DOWN IT'S IN THE MILLIONS
AND IT ALSO COSTS LIVES- WHAT I
EAT IN THIS BILL- THIS DOESN'T
TOUCH THE PROCEEDINGS
REGARDING- SEVEN TO OUR POWER
BACK UP THAT DECISION FOR TWO
FOLDERS ALREADY BEEN MADE. SO
MINIMAL COSTS IN THE REASON WHY
IS A MINIMAL COST THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE TO GET
THIS INFORMATION. A LITTLE
EXTENDED OVER THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. RIGHT NOW
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING BECAUSE
STATE STATUTE DOESN'T ALLOW ME
TO DO THAT SO IT'S A MINIMAL
COST AND CANDIDLY IT WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT BECAUSE OUR
ENTIRE AT TELECOM- WIRELESS
SYSTEM AS WELL AS CABLE SYSTEM
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
RESILIENCY THAT THIS WILL
CREATE RIGHT N. AGAIN THE
POLICY QUESTION IS DO WE JUST
PAY FOR THAT OR DO WE TRY TO
PASS ALONG EVERYBODY IN THE
BILLS MAKE THE BILL HIGHER.
MORE PEOPLE DROP OFF SO ANYWAY
THAT'S JUST THOSE ARE MY
CONCERNS WITH THAT I REALLY DO
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS IN HERE- BUT- I JUST
WISH WE WOULD WORK OUT THE
COSTS IN OUR PRIORITIES A
LITTLE BIT MORE- TECH TO BE
ABLE TO GET THESE THINGS DONE
ON THE GROUND A LOT QUICKER
THANK YOU KNOW THINKING AND
NOTHING I SAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FRESHERS
THE ISSUE IS- IN THE ANALYSIS
BY THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- IT'S- MINOR. BUT OF
DURABLE COST TO THE COMPANY
PUBLIC TOES COMMISSION I THINK
LAST. SUMMER AGUIAR-CURRY GOT A
QUESTION. THEY CALL. ON THE
PHONE OKAY. A LOT OF. REBUILT
THE PROGRAM BOB OFFERS SOMEONE
A TOP OF MIND YEAH. BIRBAL THEN
THE OFFICE WITH FOR. HER
FEATHER. FOR FIFTY YOU LOOK AT
THE NEW YORK AVE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE RUN. SUMMARY
GALLAGHER YEP JUST QUICKLY
WANTED TO THANK THE SENATOR-
FOR WORKING NOT BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE AND THIS IS. THE
LATEST ITERATION- YOU KNOW AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU DO
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS I
BROUGHT EVERYBODY TO THIS
WORKING- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY.
THE BIGGEST A HOLDERS ARE OUR
CONSTITUENTS- WHO HAVE THIS
CONCERN OF. AND WE'VE SEEN IN
HIM BOTH IN EMERGENCIES AND
WHEN WE'VE HAD THESE PS PS
EVENTS- CERTAINLY BEEN
PROBLEMATIC AND SO WE WANT TO.
FIND A WAY TO MAKE THE
SITUATION BETTER WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THESE LOSSES AND
WENT AND THIS IS WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS HOW PEOPLE
GET THEIR INFORMATION NOW I
MEAN IS A- IS IT'S NOT JUST
PHONES BUT IS YOUR INTERNET
YOUR- ALL THESE THINGS AND- YOU
KNOW THE FACTS NINE ONE ONE.
ALL THESE THINGS THAT THE ARE
ALL INTERTWINED IN THE SO. THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A MAKING REALLY
GOOD PROGRESS APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO FIND THE
RIGHT FIT HERE. TO MAXIMUM.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SAYING HEARING NONE
OF WE DO HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO CHRIS NIELSEN
AND OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
WORKING. REALLY HARD ON THIS-
WHO'S BEHIND ME AND THEN THE
LAST PIECE OF THE SAYS THIS IS
A BIPARTISAN BILL BECAUSE SO
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN IMPACTED.
BY THESE POWER SHUT OFFS IN.
LACK THE ABILITY TO CALL A
WOMAN TO RECEIVE EMERGENCY
ALERTS WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED PREPARATIONS
REPORTERS SUPPORTING REAL.
SECRETARY G. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YES HI. RODRIGUEZ AYE
SECTOR NUMBER. THIRTY NOT
VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY. R. THREE
FIVE CALDERON. CALL JOHN I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I AGREE.
GREAT FIVE WARD FORD FIVE
EXCISE THE MEASURES UP THANK
REMAINS UNDER TEARS THINKING.
SO SECRETARY LET'S GO BACK TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CAN YOU
CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. GRAY GREAT I.
SEVEN WITHOUT WILL GO UP TO THE
TOP OF OUR BILLS THE FIRST ONE
IS B. ONE OH NINE- CALLED
MISSING MEMBERS GRAY. GREAT I'D.
SEVEN NINE THE MOTIONS OUT ON
TO NUMBER TWO SB. THREE FORTY
ONE. EVERYONE THINKS THAT THAT
THE- RESULT OF WHAT WHAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATING THIS HEARING IS
OVER. THANK. WE ARRIVED.